yes cerske yeah cerski [ __ ] boy desto
dub it's awful lot of it check me out
here on the bootleg care podcast showing
y'all how to make nothing into something
bullet care podcast special guest man my
guy
desto is here man what's up welcome
welcome welcome awful lot of it yes
hey it's crazy man cause uh
we were just talking off camera about
how
the pandemic
really changed
changed things for you and i right
so you would you know for people who
don't know
i think a lot of people kind of got hips
you originally because you were you were
kind of like pumps la guy yes sir so
like peek a little pump
you were always with pump
um
and
you had always had that's an awful awful
lot of cough syrup it started with the
dicky [ __ ] right yes well i had a i
started with like a t-shirt that i made
you know it was just a t-shirt that i
made i got really started i got arrested
like probably like five five four years
ago or whatever the cop pulled me out
the car and he said hey that's an awful
lot of cough syrup because he found all
the pints in the back seat of the car
you know what i mean and then from then
on it's just like it's just always been
like this viral clip and then i always
made clothes so one day i'm just like
you know i'm steadily like
bleaching and tie-dying other people's
clothes and trying to like do stuff to
other people stuff but i never had
nothing that was mine and then i
literally was just there one day like
bro why don't i just put this on a shirt
like just that's an awful lot of coffee
and then ever since then it's just i put
it on a shirt started with one t-shirt
i used to catch the bus to the slots and
swap me
you know i'll get them heat pressed on
make like 12 shirts give away 10 sell
two the two i made i'll use two i sold
i'll use that money to make some more
damn and it's crazy too because like
during that
era like
that was really like
that was when like lean was really
booming the drug use and hip-hop i mean
it still is right but i mean like
it was like yeah it was like really
booming but it's crazy that that all
kind of
started from an actual interaction you
had from getting arrested now you turned
the negative to the positive people
yeah no it's why did you end up uh doing
time over over that no no no no i got a
lawyer got everything situated kind of
was like a deal rejected i don't know
where that came from right this isn't
even my car bro i'm using somebody
else's car
did y'all plant that there i have no
recollection that that was ever there
that's a beautiful thing man but um
you know i know you had like an option
there was a point in time where you
could have went on the road with a
little pump
but instead you didn't right yeah well
you know
it just got to a point where like me and
paul was so close because he was
literally like you know you're booming
at first and as an artist la is like the
capital of the music game
you know you can do more here in a month
than you can i mean in a day that you
could do anywhere else in a month you
know so he was living out here he was
being out here a lot and i just you know
always messed with him because he always
like a good dude you know what i mean a
good kid actually he wasn't even yeah he
was a child child like 15 yeah you know
what i mean i'm just knowing these la
streets and how they are i just told
them like you know like we're like i
don't want nothing from you at all never
have i never take anything i don't want
nothing i just want to make sure you
safe bro like like make sure you safe
because we were just coming off the no
jumper tour mm-hmm and that's when i
literally they was on tour i bought a
van filled it up with merch and just
followed the tour all the way around and
that was super early because that was
even before no jumper had really really
blown up before adam's super super early
because it was like himself
adam was a cam girl on that girl
everybody smoked per pump yeah yeah all
of them and it's yeah though that's
crazy like because that was before pump
was even pumped because i met that's
when perp was the big one because i'm at
pump at uh my homie trap zilla's crib in
in panorama city
trap because i used to go over to trap's
house and pick up packs and like you
would go over there and they'd be like
all these little viral kids that yeah
like [ __ ] six nine or pump or smoke
purp or fat nick or whoever the [ __ ]
germ like it was like
bro that it was like the soundcloud
castle it was like what is that one uh
show a movie called speaker city or
something there's just [ __ ] pounds of
wheat everywhere
[ __ ]
dogs keys there's all kinds of wild [ __ ]
going on in panorama city and i met lil
pump and i was like yo this is crazy
because this is like a child like a kid
bro bro yeah it was a wild like time but
you know um
i just talked to i had fat nick up here
a few days ago
and i told him i was like hey bro
not for nothing but whenever i talk
about 2017
20 like end of 2016 2017 2018 i always
kind of refer to it as like
the dark age of hip-hop
it was like when like half emo half
hip-hop it was like yeah it was that and
it was also the age of like
people were just getting signed over ig
antics
like there was like you know i think
supreme patty got a record deal you know
what i'm saying like there was like it
was it was the dark age for the music
industry because there was so much
[ __ ] that was getting
signed like think about what was that
kid's name that we talked about um who
said he was a clone like kid buu got a
[ __ ] record deal and his music is
terrible
like he got something
it was just so much [ __ ] and you know
what it was was everyone was trying to
get the next pump
they realized at that time that okay
we're looking for people that make music
to build them a fan base when we have
these kids that's on instagram that
already have fan bases they have
followers though followers equals fans
sometimes
sometimes not always well back then yeah
sometimes at that time if you had a
million or not even a million you could
have 300 000 but your antics was getting
you 20 000 a week 10 000 a week you know
your engagements that's what they're
looking at your engagements your
followers how many followers you get how
many people are watching this post and
they're just the same thing with youtube
same thing with myspace people were
getting signed off of these things
instagram
you'd be like dude like it'd be like a
guy like little gnar right who's a good
dude right but he would just do wild
[ __ ] on ig and got a record deal because
he was just blowing [ __ ] up and firing
bazookas and just doing all kind of ill
[ __ ]
and it was like man like
what happens when
the music doesn't
match the
[ __ ] [ __ ] because if eventually you got
to come through with that music
eventually do and some people because
you can't just keep outdoing yourself on
instagram because because then you're
going to be able to bring you
you're going to be turning yourself out
yeah you're going to end up like the uh
what was that dude did john gabbana do
what would you would he
like that [ __ ] guy you know what i'm
saying like went too crazy went too
crazy but it's crazy because you were
really a part of that whole era
you were there bro
i was there orchestrating making sure
they were straight making sure they
didn't take too much of that do too much
this you know what i mean like i was
around all of them that's when i like
people don't know i did tattoos
so like you know a lot of these kids
like i tatted boom gang face before i
tied it pump face i was tired of smoke
purp i tried a lot of people i even tied
at nipsey so like a lot of these people
like when that phase was going on i was
going around them so i don't know
probably we probably going around them
doing their tattoos you know what i mean
going around you know selling on my
merch giving them my merch because if
they wear it and they got a fan base oh
it's so fancy
it's a movie
what um what was it like kind of being
the adult in the room in that in a lot
of those situations
just really like bro y'all tripping
there's just a lot of brain out
trippings
you know what i mean like i would
partake in certain stuff but it was
really like
even though i was the adult
they really like punk bro he had this
instagram [ __ ] broke down to a science
like to a science you'll think he was
just no i'm doing this no he knew that
like if i did this with that
then this would happen
yeah he got himself signed off on
instagram you know what i mean like he
knew how to get the people to watch
videos like we didn't literally sit down
and spent like an hour to just creating
a scenario just so that he can make a
[ __ ] 30 second video to post that'll
go viral
you know that's how he went from
a couple of hundred thousand followers
to like 17 million mm-hmm it happened
fast you know what i mean the pump
should happen every antique or something
that he would do it will blow him up
he'll get more followers he'll get more
fans he'll get more engagements he'll
get more money everybody can't relate
instagram into money he's actually
transferring them likes views
engagements into actual hard cash
what it what do you think like um
because obviously pump is still going to
be able to make
money off of music forever or at least
off of being little pump but i think
that like the potential of pump
and where he is now
probably aren't
where where we all thought it was going
to end up right where do you think like
pump [ __ ] kind of went left for him like
like i'm not saying he's like down down
bad or anything but you know him and
perp like obviously
i i assume pump was going to be a
superstar you know what happened this is
why i think
pump like honestly he records every day
every time i call him he records every
day
he stopped putting out
music
like you know like he has a fan base bro
like he has he has this star power
bottom that if anybody between a certain
age sees him or knows of him
a week later they're going to be
mimicking something that he does
you know what i mean so when he went to
music this is what i'll be trying to get
around to too
when he like a lot of people put energy
into what they want
you know what i mean you want to be a
rapper you want to be this you're going
to put energy into it but if you took
that same energy and put it into
anything else you'd probably be way more
you know up than what you think he was
so like he was recording this stuff but
he wasn't putting the music out so it
was just like you know it's just like
working out every day but not like like
just being in the house you're not it's
not going to anything when you're and
when you're not feeding those fans
you're not feeling good
they go to their job they're going to
other rappers and they want music bro
yeah like even if good bad whatever it
is you just got to keep pumping it out i
feel like 69 benefited from pump kind of
stopping putting out as much music
because he started putting on because he
was kind of like
an evolution of what pump was doing on
the internet
yeah but he just went south because he
wants super gangster but but exactly he
just went super sad he like went super
gangsta when it was like right were you
around six nine at all back like no he
was coming
i i did like a show before you know
because i know he was in la a lot yeah
he was he was but like i wasn't really
around dealing that you feel me like
already at that point i was just making
sure punk was straight at all times
how's your relationship with pump now oh
we're great i can facetime right now
pick up on the first call he calls me x
about my daughter you know every time
you have a show you ask me if i want to
go like bro we're going to dubai i'm
like man i can't go to the market my
wife will start tripping i just jump up
and go to dubai with a little pump today
you know what i mean maybe i'm gonna go
to dubai with that's crazy
um next week no you're not yeah and i
got a newborn now so it's like you know
i got daddy duties um i remember there
was a certain point in time where
you obviously being associated with
being
the lean guy yeah i was a juice man
um
you know i know the first rapper that i
saw
kind of come out
and someone who i knew every time i
would see was that was [ __ ] high off
his ass was mozzie
mozzie did the kick the cup [ __ ] right
yeah
and um
i know some people were like man that's
corny whatever but i thought it was dope
but i remember when you posted that
i was like this is big man because you
got it you got a whole different grip on
some of these kids and the way they look
up to you
and i know that that's not an easy thing
to stay off of i mean i'm not saying
people don't people don't relapse they
don't [ __ ] up or because that's a hard
just bigger than like like whether you
do it or you don't the biggest part is
not to do it in the public eye not to
glorify you right yeah like not to like
like honestly bro i could sit right here
take a picture promoting my album do
whatever promoted my clothes it'll do
whatever to do now if i was to put a
bottle a lien
a double cup or actually put me pouring
the lean while i'm telling something
gonna get more like more of you 300 400
000 more views than then percent more
views than the regular one but the thing
again is like bro like i'm not just
trying to like you know i got brothers
so when i see my little brother pouring
up you know spending his money on trying
to sip and it's like these kids don't
know what they doing they can they
grabbing anything and just pouring it in
a soda
so that's when i kind of stepped back
from just like you know glorifying it or
like putting it out there you know what
i mean i also feel like you look a lot
healthier man hell yeah
bro that like people don't really know
like that [ __ ] really takes you over
like i went from like
170 pounds to like 250 like you know
what i mean that's what you were saying
he was like bro i had to get off that
[ __ ] cause i was getting fat bro you get
so big and it's not even the lean it's
the soda cause you're drinking so much
soda yeah there's so much soda about two
three four five 20 ounces a day a 2
liter 2 2 liters a day all that's going
in your face going in your body and then
it [ __ ] up your inside bro like to a
point where like i was using the
restroom and it was blood oh wow like
like they don't tell you about that part
like you'll be spitting it'll be blood
and you'll spit you know and that's
normal like that's normal
and it's like nah bro this can't be how
was it hard to um because you know
obviously with any sort of opiate it's
not the easiest thing hell yeah it's
hard but then you just kind of like get
through the withdrawals yeah you'll get
through it it's like i'm not saying you
just go cold turkey that's when it [ __ ]
you up but you go from that's where you
might go to the hospital yeah you're
pouring a pint of daily like you know
now i'm only doing like you'll do like
an eight of them right then from there
you'll just do like a cut whenever your
stomach start really hurting and then
after that you just kind of like tone it
down to where you're probably only
sipping like
once a day then you sipping like
once a week then it's to like you really
don't even sip like that yeah i feel
like too like that era of hip-hop where
the drug use and the lean use was ultra
glorified
back then i mean fentanyl was always a
thing but i feel like now it's really
yeah that's another thing that slows you
down on a lot of that
yeah but they don't be putting the
fitting all in a drink but it's just
like the price of the drink so high and
then the price of drinks are high you go
to pills they try to get appeals and
then the pills is fake laced you know
what i mean you don't know what you get
nowadays you could so it's just kind of
just best to just stay away from all
that [ __ ] bro so talk about um
you know cause for people who don't know
you took the the clothing brand from
being downtown setting up shop in your
van that was always getting how many
times did this van get broken into bruh
the birdman get broken into at least
like two or three times a month which
just got up man that's because that's
the thing i stayed in an apartment
building an apartment building didn't
have parking for the van it's only you
know it only had car parking so i would
park next door to my apartment building
in a parking lot and it was an open
public parking lot that you could just
pay and park your car and then i would
sit there all day grinding and then at
night you gotta understand half of the
break-ins was just smokers
just a smoker who i'll probably walk
past during the day see this
[ __ ] jumping come back at night
and ain't nobody there now they trying
to pry their way up in there and the
crazy part i had it reinforced i had the
back door reinforced i had you know
these bands that go seat then it's open
so i had like a cage i literally built a
cage where i kept all the merchandise
didn't stop them they'll break into it
just to try to steal some pennies out of
the out of the [ __ ] cup holder yeah
you know a shirt that's damaged just
sitting in the front you know shirts are
like 120 so they're breaking in trying
to get a sock if they could they don't
care
no i but you you were pretty much
setting up shop downtown hustling out
the van
walk me through the progression on how
you grew the business to
because you have you you don't have the
downtown space anymore that was like
temporary right what you're like a
retail space downtown oh i got it oh you
still got it so you have that and you
got melrose yes so you got two locations
two 2.5 2.5 three locations
that's crazy so kind of walk me through
how the brand really blew because i feel
like it really really happened
it was always a thing where we would see
people wearing it would see like adam
wearing it or pump wearing it but like
now it's like a legitimate
like you said man like you know it was
important for you to come up here and
explain to people that you don't gotta
sell drugs or play balls
none of that like this is my thing this
is my whole
testimony this is what i want everybody
to know you do the same energy that
these kids these grown men these women
any person is putting into trying to
play a sport which the likely the
likeliness of you making it into
impossible impossible you know but you
spend like you spend so much money so
much time so much effort trying to be a
basketball player trying to be a
football player trying to play this play
soccer play whatever you spend so much
time trying to be a rapper trying to be
a singer playing for versus paying for
studio time paying for engineers
traveling back and forth to the studio
if you put that same energy into a
business whether it's you could put that
same energy into selling shoestrings
now i'm going to shoot now i'm going to
come every shoe convention selling every
person there in my shoe strings you know
i'm making different shoe strings for
different days different holidays you
know if you put that same energy into
making a business you'll win now how i
started was like i said
it came to the point where pump was
moving out of lane he moved back to
miami you know adam you know he still
had no jumper but he closed down the
store and he moved to burbank where he
was just doing podcasts right so i was
like
do i want to
just you know jump into the field and
stay riding with adam do i want to go to
miami state rider with pump
and it's like no i gotta i'm about to
stay here in la and start from the
ground up because once people don't
understand what you're hanging out with
these high profile artists even if
you're a best friend a best buddy that's
still their money not yours facts yeah
you get free stuff yeah you get a piece
of something you get the perks of it but
it's still theirs right like i'm i can
tell you from 2018 to 2019 i roll in
nothing less than the mercedes-benz it
wasn't mine
you know what i mean i had new clothes
shoes everything but i didn't pay for
them i would go to the store with
somebody and they'll buy like 20 000
worth of stuff buy me two or three pair
of shoes buy me a shirt and some pants
now that's more than most people but
it's still not me with my hard-earned
cash because when i leave them i don't
have [ __ ]
so when he decided to leave i just
decided to stay here and it basically
started with
i knew i had this product that people
wanted i had about 80 000 followers so
i'm like if i can just sell one or two
hoodies a day which is about two three
hundred dollars a day
then that's eating you know what i mean
so i hired me a driver you know because
i didn't even have a license i didn't
have a car once left i didn't have [ __ ]
to drive
so you know i started off fighting me a
driver one of my best buddies eddie and
we would lit out literally all day long
hey who want a hoodie on my story who
want this who want that i'll go through
my request find one or two people get
their number get their address and put
it on the next day i'll pull up on them
you know so i was doing that for about
like two to three months i did that so
much that i moved out of my downtown
apartment and got me and my girl spot in
westchester
and i was doing all that off of just
basically instagram finding people
wearing my stuff promoting my stuff like
if i wear it i'll know i'll go through
my comments oh i need that click um okay
you want that where are you at now like
okay you here send me your address i'm
gonna pull up on you wow and i'm gonna
bring it so i did so i did that for
about two or three months then it got to
a point where like i would have so many
people to pull up on i wouldn't make it
and besides that i was putting up in
some sketchy ass places
you know i'm pulling up and like
[ __ ] like you got anywhere
yeah i got money i'm pulling up real
nice you know that sometimes people will
send me the address next door to their
house and i'll pull up and i'll see like
six people hopping out the hopping out
of a different address i'm like hold on
why are they coming from back there
right to over here but you know in god's
good god's will you know it's always
been good
but then it just got to a point where i
didn't even have enough stuff we had
like a 92
nissan sentra oh wow that's what we was
riding around in and then it got to the
point where and this is all right before
the corona started and everything but
right before the corona started like
probably three months four months before
the corona started it started being like
damn bro like i can't even carry enough
stuff for people i would pull up on one
person he'll want a 2x or 3x then he'll
have his boy who want another large and
a small so it's like bro i can't carry
all this in the central so then i
invested in a van
once i invested in a van we would do the
deliveries in a van but and we'll have
more merchandise but then what this is
when everybody was running when people
were running around picking up kids in
vans
so i was like i'm running around getting
my money in this van getting pulled over
two to three times a day because it's
just a white van
you know they pulling me out searching
the whole van
so then it's just like bruh first of all
i can't make it to all these people
second of all i'm getting pulled over
left and right i don't have a license
you know like every time i pull over i
gotta switch seats with my boy like jump
in the driver's seat bro
they trip it so then it just got to a
point where
corona hit and then more people wanted
stuff when corona hit all the stores was
closed yep you know and nothing people
didn't realize once all the store closed
i mean a lot of business was closed trap
went up it was more people selling more
wheat more people selling it was booming
and edd was booming so now it's like
people are making more money with
nowhere to spend it but these high-end
stores because like other stores was
closed because that's when it was doing
the break-ins and all of this because
that was right around the same time it
was black lives matter
so like a lot of stores closed down that
wasn't black because people was kicking
in the doors once the jewish floyd [ __ ]
happened right
so i just found a parking lot right next
to my building
that the like i didn't even pay for
parking at the time because the workers
wasn't there because it was corona um
so it got to a point where i'm like yeah
just meet me right here downtown just
meet me right here downtown pull up to
the van yeah pull up pull up right here
i'm right here in this parking lot pull
up on me and that's when it was like
after that like my worker wasn't with me
he was kind of sometimes with me but
i'll just be like i got this now so i'll
literally park there
all morning like i'll get there like 11
10 park still go through my dms you want
it you got to pull up here and get it
you want it you got to pull up here and
get it so then now they're pulling up to
the van
they're pulling up to the van to grab it
all day long wow you know and that's
when it really started booming you know
then it got to a point where my
manufacturer was closed
so i could still get the blanks but i
had nobody to print printed out yeah so
then i'm like [ __ ] it i'm about to start
doing my own printing so i would sell a
clothes during the day and at night i
would be in my apartment screen printing
the shirts screen printing you bought
your own screen printer on screen
everything it wasn't no middleman
everybody was closed you know a business
they'll suit they'll tax your ass for
staying open during the pantheon yep
everything so now i'm making my own [ __ ]
next day i'm going in the parking lot if
somebody coming they wanted something
out of half i'll make it the next night
take a deposit bring it give it to them
the next day yep you know and then with
that being said stuff started opening
back up everything started being cool
you know i still had all these high-end
friends and clients so when they come
there i'm like man just pull up to the
parking lot i got you so now you got
like pee wee long way you got a little
pump you got young thug you got a little
duke you got all these people pulling up
to this parking lot buying stuff and i'm
actually recording it the whole time so
now the next person to see it and want
to come to the parking lot themselves
that's crazy so then from there it's
like the parking lot was booming you got
corona going on all of the stores is
closed i'm making all of the clothes by
myself by hand
um
it's no competition because nothing else
is open and everybody had
each other everyone got money everybody
got money so you did like an awful lot
of edd yeah i made an awful lot cause i
like i consider myself high in street
wear for sure and
what's more about the streets than edd
for sure that was like the billboard for
the streets i can't wait till that
documentary comes out hey what up man we
got to interrupt the interview real
quick to tell you about our family at
odd socks now when i be riding for odd
socks so hard man it's because i really
love the product they got the most
comfortable socks in the [ __ ] world i
got a pair of odd socks basics on right
now go get those they got the socks wwe
joints you what i'm saying shout out to
the undertaker pepsi [ __ ]
really whatever you need some weed socks
nickelodeon but really they got the
draws now ladies and gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapateo underwear
right now
you want some pop tarts on your dick
pop tart draws and these [ __ ]
are so comfortable
like
man so listen you gotta go to
oddssoxofficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev
at oddssocksofficial.com you'll save 20
off underwear the most comfortable socks
in the world crazy licenses not only
they got the wwe they got the scarface
they got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website oddsoxofficial.com
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview yeah yeah when they do a
documentary about the edd and ppp [ __ ]
it's gonna be a movie cause a lot of
people won't know about it was really
just a california thing that's real cali
hat was like they had people from all
over the world flying to cali just to
run edd it was like if you was a scammer
this is like your golden year this is
like the gold rush for scammers it was
the gold rush bro there's people who i
knew were broke as [ __ ] that were riding
around in like maybach i'm like bro what
the [ __ ] just like all of the underdogs
that really wasn't making it or started
making it because they have to time and
they could do it so it went from like me
selling a few hoodies a day to me making
like five six seven eight nine ten
thousand a day in the parking lot with
no overhead with no overhead no overhead
10 bands a day every day without the no
questions out the van i started hiring
employees to work at the van like kids
that i could trust because it's
dangerous out there but the crazy part
is i used to work at the parking lot
selling and then since there was nobody
there the lights never cut on so after
the light to cut off i mean after it get
dark in the parking lot i would drive to
benny hibachi and post next today van
because if you simply eat him benny
hibachi you know about awful lot of
cough syrup of course so i would do like
yo if for people who don't know you go
downtown to benibachi that [ __ ] is
that's just booming yeah you'll be like
anybody anybody who's in town grabbing
work or whatever they're all at benny
about hibachi with offline concert
tracks you know straight up so i would
park right there and just sell today
clients and vice versa you know people
pull up to buy stuff from me and go to
them you know then i think it got around
like
like you said people started breaking
into the van the parking people started
coming back after corona they started
telling me i can't park there and i buy
like five six seven parking spots now
what's the problem now then they're like
okay this is a parking lot you can't
have your clothes just set up in the
parking lot with tables and stuff so
then i bought another van i would keep
one of them we'll keep the merchandise
of storage the other one i'll have like
displays out so when they pull up so
it's like if you just drive past you
wouldn't see nothing but two vans but if
you know this is really where you get
the awful lot of cough syrup at and with
that being said me dealing with all
these high-end artists they'll post it
on ingram and it'd be like a hidden gem
that you can't get to like where's this
at like nobody posted the address but i
see everybody in this parking lot in
downtown l.a with dub you know i mean i
never would really post address i'll
just people want to know people you know
you know you got to figure it out yeah
you got to figure it out
so from there i got uh he just was so
much getting broken into police starting
to harass me i think like i had a few
robberies down there where people would
like follow my clients and rob on
because they know like i'm talking big
dogs really put out there spending like
two three thousand on cough surgery yeah
and it's one of the things where you'll
buy it because when you go home your
homie wants it or you can sell it to
your homie for more right you know
so then i got an opportunity to get a
store on melrose i met a guy he was like
hey i got a store you know with the
corona only got paid 25 percent of the
rent right now i don't want to be in
here we're good until like for like six
months if you give me six months worth
of rent you know the rent is like
probably like six seven thousand just
give me like 25 3 500
a month and i'll let you keep it but you
got to pay it all up front
so i'm like all right well i'm gonna
give him like 15 bands
15 minutes i was supposed to be good for
like five six months you know what i
mean
second month they start cutting the
lights off in the building on melrose
[ __ ] they like they locked the front
door changed the locks on the front door
you know what i mean but this is still
corona so you really technically can't
lock people out
you know what i mean
but then it just got to a point where i
had so much inventory in there and they
just like look after this date we're
going to lock the doors and have this
this was a letter from the sheriff's
we're going to lock the doors and you're
not going to be able to get anything out
so that was like february i was
literally only there for like a month
but within that month i probably made
like a million dollars wow just being on
melrose
jesus like probably two months to be
exact two months by the third month i
was like i gotta get up out of here you
know what i mean so
by the third month it's like [ __ ] i
really gotta leave um i'm looking for
different locations i'm searching
you know they're still putting trying to
cut the lights off they got the landlord
it's coming down
you know so by exactly like the fourth
month i found downtown
i got signed the lease for downtown
right next to the parking lot that i
used to sell out of so it was all right
there all kind of worked out yeah so
then i got that spot then like once i
got that spot a week later somebody hit
me back for a spot on melrose
another spot on melrose so then i take
that one too
wow well you have the old on some [ __ ]
right yeah so yeah look so on some [ __ ]
was the first building i have next door
and next door oh wow okay okay okay yeah
so the middle building uh uh
i got in the third one
and you can you kind of started selling
in front of his store right that's where
i started that's before like before when
i was still on tour with pump yeah i
would get up on sundays and just post in
front of adam store because everybody
know me there yeah and everybody was
pulling up because they were like
wanting to run into whoever the yeah
that's what they do they pull up there
to run into whoever's popular or
something first oh dub yeah okay you
know me you want a hoodie i got these
new hoodies yeah you know even though my
ground you still see to this day i don't
delete nothing you can see when i was
still there right selling in front of
adams and now you got the spot now i got
the spot now i got two of the spots
that's just crazy man
now i just think it's dope because
i've been just watching the progression
and like i was in miami and
uh shout out to ghazi we're at his
birthday party and future walks in
wearing the hat and i was like man look
at this guy man that was like one of the
biggest things for me in future work
because it's like without future and
coding crazy there will be no awful lot
of costs there facts like i was
listening to march madness when i got
pulled over wow
like on repeat like on repeat bro i was
listening to nothing that's what future
was going monster marching band
uh uh uh fifty six nine six nights like
he was going so crazy bro i was on
repeat if it wasn't for future it
wouldn't mean i have a lot of cops there
what um
for you like who's been somebody who
supported i mean first of all you've
been doing a bunch of collabs
you talked about benny abacha you just
did a collab with them you just did west
coast customs so this was my thing once
i got the store on melrose
my game plan was and i just got the
store just got the store in january this
month that was the first store then i
got kicked out in like april then i got
downtown in may and then by the end of
may i got the other melrose store so
this is all don't think like this took
like literally within a month i went
from a parking lot to like
buying a million dollar crib owning a
rolls-royce having three
uh three three commercial stores you
know like within like nine to ten months
i did all of that you know what i mean
so i just wanted people to think like
you know at that time i kind of like
i think it really went crazy after i
just told myself like look i know i know
how to rap i know how to make music but
it's really a hobby at this time it's a
hobby spending money on recording i'm
spending money on entertaining artists
spending money
i slowed down on making music and put
more time into the clothes
okay because you were rapping you were
dude yeah i still rap i got a whole
mixtape with hit boy right now we just
dropped our first single like like two
three weeks ago you kind of just
put more effort into hey look this i
mean because look at the end of the day
if you're pulling even if you're making
five grand a day in that parking lot
like early right
imagine making 10 like getting to the
point where you're like damn i'm making
10 grand now this is [ __ ] crazy then
you go to that melrose spot for however
long it was
a million dollars in a month
this is a
astronomical amount of money crazy
amount of money and then with the price
point your margins got to be crazy yeah
yeah and then like i said like once i
got like i told myself when i go to
melrose like the this is my whole plan
the year went out the year before i
moved like the year before the parking
lot it was like okay i'm gonna try to
make a million dollars this year a
million dollars a year is only 3 000 a
day
now just because you made a million a
year that don't mean you're going to
have a million yeah because you're
getting overhead yeah so after the first
year of me and i knew i could make a
million the next year i'm like i got to
make more than a million so i can put a
million up you're gonna have a million
in the bank yeah i want to have a
million in the bank so then now i'm like
how do i do that how do i expand my
expand my clothing line
i do collapse
once i get this storefront i'm gonna do
a collab every month i mean i'm gonna
exchange my customers with other people
customers you know if you got a clothing
line we do a collab you get mine i get
yours but one thing that they're gonna
know that this is where you need to go
to get it
so i went from doing collapse every
month to where like now i'm doing a
collab like every two weeks who have you
done collabs with so far
i mean you've done a lot so
uh
like i said um
i did two collabs for young thug i'm
about to do a collab with gunna
um i did a collab with my boy assali i
did a collab with betty hibachi i did a
collab with no jumper i did a collab
with west coast customs i did a collab
with once
um
who else
that's like six a lot it's a lot a lot
like exotic pop you know i grinded so
hard and i've been messing with exotic
pop they gave me my own soda it's
probably one of the number one sodas
everywhere you can see it at any smoke
shop liquor store grocery market
anywhere any place detroit l.a atlanta
texas booming new york they're
everywhere
you know what i mean
um
who else um i'm working on some stuff
with travis uh
uh travis barker
are you like interested in
because i think what makes your [ __ ] so
fire and what ethica
ethica
shout out to ethica it's an interesting
place over there um
but you you you've done like
you're able to sell the [ __ ] you sell
at the price point you're selling it not
only because it's fly but also because
it's hard to come by hard to come by and
the people that's wearing it
right so my question to you is
are you
doubling down on the exclusivity of like
what you're doing or like let's say
hypothetically speaking zoomies comes to
the table and they're like we want to
put your [ __ ] in our store is that
something you would even entertain at
this point see this is the thing
yes i would
for a minute i would say like no no i
wouldn't but this is the thing
people like oh you're doing a lot of
collabs oh it's not as rare as it what
bro these collabs i'm not doing a
thousand pieces all these collabs are
limited runs right if you didn't get it
at the pop-up you'll probably never see
it you just did something with vezo you
just did some [ __ ] while i was wearing
videos yeah there's so many collabs
where it's like i can't even keep up but
it's like it's so limited you know what
i mean like me and vizio we probably
only made about a hundred pieces you
know they're like we're making like
enough to go online to go here to go
there no you gotta post these pieces you
gotta pull up and then it creates the
demand for it and if the demand is high
enough i might redo it and put it online
but besides that bro if you don't get it
in person now i do have items that i
reprint you know like certain t-shirts
certain t-shirt styles like i have a
flip of a waffle house shirt that's
constantly on my website that's
constantly in my store it's a shirt but
certain hoodies and certain stuff like
that you can't get it you know what i
mean like this this hoodie right here
like if you don't get it when it's
online and it pops up within a month
it's gone forever you know what i mean
do you see like does your [ __ ] like end
up on ebay and like end up online
i was in fred siegel like like that [ __ ]
is everywhere like wow and it's it's not
on stockx but i see it on holy grail you
know it holds it value i had to go to us
the second street store on melrose they
were buying my stuff and reselling it
wow
you know what i mean and the thing about
it they was buying fake [ __ ] that's how
high the demand is i walked in and i
seen fake [ __ ] that that was mine and
they were selling like bro it's not even
coffee like it's not even my brand i
never made this shirt in my life wow
so a hose of value has a great resale
value has a great resale value out of
town out of town people are selling my
shirts for 300 350. are you still
handling the productions handling
everything every piece of shirt that you
done wore i didn't touched it i didn't
designed it i did something to it
there's nothing that go past me without
these hands touching it that's crazy man
now i think it's dope because like you
said man i just think that like
being an entrepreneur in hip-hop is
sometimes feels so
far away and un like like when we see
like when we think of entrepreneurs in
hip-hop or in the culture we think of
like jay-z or we think of like nahs like
invested in ring and like but like you
is to me like your story is a perfect
example of
anybody no matter where you're at in
life
it's not hard to get from
a 2 a 92 centra
to a [ __ ] bentley or whatever you
know what i'm saying like it's not and
that's the thing you just people aren't
directing their energy and they time the
right place bro like everybody wants to
be a rapper everybody wants to play
sports bro do something else just try it
you been rapping for what three four
years what to just get a few views on
youtube that pays you pennies on the
[ __ ] you know to get some [ __ ] on
soundcloud to get some [ __ ] on itunes
yeah when bro if you just take that same
energy and push your own clothing line
push your own merch was it was it was it
hard for you initially to like um just
figure out the
you know like
we're in l.a so there's the garment
district like it's not hard to get
wholesale [ __ ] oh it's not i used to
wake up every morning not every morning
but every time i wake up early i'll just
go downtown to like it's between 14th
and main and
17th in maine and then it goes from
maine los angeles
santa fe all of them bro you can
literally it's people besides me there's
people that go there all these girls
with them online boutiques they go there
buy the stuff selling stuff all these
littles yeah there's like spots like you
know i'm from phoenix so there's girls
who open up boutiques in phoenix and all
they do is come to l.a
buy stuff pennies on the dollar and they
just yeah little dresses little all that
[ __ ] so it was like i used to just wake
up and just walk downtown and see what i
can put my logo on like i'll walk like
i'll today i'll go on the block i'll
walk in that store see what y'all got
walk in the next door see what y'all got
okay can i get one of those one of those
i'll go back make samples and then i'll
go back and buy more but like that would
be a part of my routine i would wake up
go downtown restock on whatever blanks i
can open up the van sell them pieces
then at night i'll make new pieces post
them on my ground so people can see
what's coming out tomorrow then the next
day it'll be for sale bro it's so crazy
because
the reason why i love your story is
because look when i was in high school
the reason i got the name bootleg kev
was because from the ages of 16 to about
19
i was at the swap meet every saturday
and sunday in phoenix
remember when the picture tease used to
be popping with the heat presses i was
running three heat presses at the same
time doing the scarface picture tees the
tupac mug shot tees all that [ __ ]
meanwhile getting all the bootleg dunks
from [ __ ] china getting all the
bootleg purses from china all the
bootleg nfl jerseys from china
and i had that [ __ ]
booming but i literally be out there
in my [ __ ] pathfinder with heat
presses and a [ __ ] pc
[ __ ] will pull up like yo i
want this on a shirt i was like cool
come back in 30 minutes i have your
shirt ready you know what i'm saying and
like i just i was i bro
the hardest part was figuring out where
to get blank shirts and all that [ __ ]
but once you figure that [ __ ] out bro
like there's really no excuse man like
and i just think that like that that
kind of like
story isn't glorified enough bro like
and and you know we always look at uh
rappers and the quick come up and
everybody want that and the clout and
the fame and all that [ __ ] i'm like bro
at the end of the day what matters is
like financial stability like no matter
how you get it and sometimes you just
gotta go a different route like like you
it's probably like whoever watching this
you sitting at home doing whatever
you're doing you're filming let's say
you're sitting at home just watching
this tv on your couch and you drink a
soda you put it down oh why don't we
have coasters
now let's say i'm not saying you're
going to make become rich off of just
coasters it's about your mindset too
it's about making a better coaster it's
about putting more time in the coast
it's about promoting these coasters i
mean you said shoelaces there's little
companies who kill it in the shoelace
game like you can go and just like okay
hey you're like just you don't even got
to be a big person you could have a
friend
pick your friend with the most followers
tell him you want to make that person a
shoelace
have them promote that shoelace today
ten thousand twenty thousand whatever
now out of that you're gonna get people
buying it find somebody else you're
gonna get get more people buying it find
another person now you're growing your
people and you're growing a catalog of
shoelaces you can do that with anything
bro pencils you coasters uh my boy
exotic pop just did it with sodas yeah
now he's killing him
pop [ __ ] is booming he went and just
started getting stuff that people
already use from different places using
these artists to
promote it once this artist drink it now
all his fans want it we're gonna have to
go back to get it do you yeah now you're
giving these artists their own sodas
you know what i mean like come on like
there's so many ways people y'all can
get it just stop trying to follow
everybody else sometimes you just need
to see how they do it and take that and
do it your own way hats i know homie
right now killing it at hats
he's buying regular hats spray painting
on him putting his design on them
selling them cracking fools for them not
even like even like the stitch joints
like
you know they're like like you said you
just got to find your lane i mean just
keep going at it you know go from just
buying
go first you're just buying a hat
putting a little something on it now get
your packaging together now get your
labels together now get your photography
up now get your promotion together now
once you got a little money pay people
to wear it pay models to wear you know
what i mean pay people to do commercials
for it bless the right people with your
[ __ ] you know what i mean and it's gonna
grow i promise you it's gonna grow
faster than your music career
it's crazy because um obviously with
guys like thug who have been big
supporters of you like when thug pulls
up do you just bless him what thug gets
everything when it first comes out
whether he like it or not
boom as soon as i make it he damn near
gets the samples some samples he get if
he wears i will not make it just because
it's just for him
that's fine like he would like i had a
lot of people wear it but a lot of
people aren't as influential as him i
can promise you that guy first hand has
helped me make majority of the money i
make today because it's not like okay
thug put it on i'm selling a lot of more
hoodies to all these people no once doug
put it on the people that i already know
is buying it faster yeah for sure i've
only got 10 people now they know thugs
on i want that's my boy hey man i need
that one now they're buying it faster
and now that they're buying it faster
people are seeing them in it and when he
put it on it just turns it turns from
just being a t-shirt that i wear to
support the homie to drip so now people
really trying to like top him and it's
not even just him because it's like if
you notice thug don't be posting
pictures of my [ __ ] he don't have to
right he really doesn't have to because
the people around him that are so big
that see him wearing it
i'll get a text from whoever like oh you
must have seen thug in it that's why
you're hitting me up right you know what
i mean once he started wearing it all of
these people that already knew me wanted
it more and faster and quicker
makes sense man
have you had any um
bigger
retail people reach out or
you know
you think of like a clothing line like
cookies right shout out to burner
cookies is [ __ ] one of the first
people to talk to me about doing the
collab but never went together but a
whole lot of that's an awful lot of
cookies would be crazy cookies
um but you know obviously he he figured
out a way to scale it to where it's of i
mean obviously
their shirts are 35 dollars not 120
but um
you know he's really mastered we just
had him on the podcast last week he said
cookies is the clothing line 60 million
a year
which is crazy have you had interest in
like people coming in trying to
maybe either like a big retailer or
someone trying to come in and like
partner with you to take it to another
level well no not like like like i said
i'm i'm in fred seagulls
yeah first he goes i'm in webster's in
miami and they have like two or three
other stories that carry my stuff but
then again like i don't give them too
much
you know like i still like i'm kind of
old school i'm sorry i like to control
my own stuff i have a few buddies they
got a clothing line called tooliness
they don't do retail they don't do
wholesale they don't do nothing
everything that they do goes through
them and their warehouse and their
things so like i kind of like that you
know i mean i like being a
majority shareholder the only person
with the most you know what i mean so
like people really feel that because i
feel like since i haven't spread my
wings all the way out
that it just makes people want to come
in more because it's like he could
really go there i can go to tilly's
right now get a deal where my [ __ ] is in
august but you wait wait it out man
build your leverage up more
i don't need to i'm saying like two
three years from now you get that that
that mother offer where you're like okay
i'm good for life now let's go come on
man let's go i'm waiting for the right
one but so you and you and hit boy
putting out a project together like for
people who don't know you're you're
you're from the same area as nipsy right
yes sir
so you and nipsey like um i know when he
passed that that hurt you a lot but like
how was your guy's relationship you said
you tattooed him in the past um nip was
one of the first people with a platform
that believed in me whatever i did now i
told you i didn't like i would do music
you [ __ ] my music i made clothes
before awful lot of costume you with my
clothes i did other things i did tattoos
he [ __ ] with my tattoos he just always
said whatever you got bro you got it and
you need to run with it like you know
what i mean he was the first person to
start inviting me to the studio you know
like hey come over here i want you to be
a part of this you know we're doing it
we're filming this i want you to come
here
a double o i need you here for this a
double i need you here for that so like
you know
for somebody smaller when you have
somebody with such a platform believing
in you it kind of just gives you that
extra like energy to keep going
motivation yeah sometimes it's hard to
keep going if money is coming in he
low-key motivated me to keep going until
i find my right little itch in twitch
you know what i mean anything i ever did
he supported it the fullest what did you
tattoo on nip uh i did the s on his face
i did all my um a and b on his back i
did uh when he finally got off probation
i did finally free on his hands
and that was probably that was pretty i
did like three tattoos on that what did
you do on pump on pump i did a gang get
[ __ ] on pump bro
it was a point where we were overseas
doing tour bro every night we would
escadate you know what i mean in
different languages on our arms and on
other people so if we're in switzerland
we'll get a schedule in switzerland if
we're in [ __ ]
uh
uh what does the uh portugal will get in
spain you know what i mean like we're
just going crazy you know i mean i would
take i would have my attack gun i would
have my clothes everywhere i went yeah
the escada thing was it was i know a
girl who does radio who got it tattooed
on her wrist
she got escaped her hair i was like yo
i was tatting that on everybody in sight
like if you wanted to get it i would
give it to you
it's free tattoos free tattoos
that's crazy it's legendary yeah it is
legendary would you ever open like a
tattoo shop for sure yeah already in the
works of it it's just right now um
so this is my biggest thing i'm doing
clothes clothes is so popping right now
i'm about to do a collab with backpack
boys i'm about to do a collab with alien
labs i'm doing a collab with all of
these people just the laptops right no
alien laps that's the that's connected
okay okay okay connected to the alien
that's a wii company what am i i'm
thinking of alienware yeah that's what
i'm thinking of so the thing is it's
like
okay let's say um all these people are
coming to me for to do collabs i mean
they like what i got they like my
material they like everything so i
started the agency so now after you come
and you do a collab with me let me let
me design your merch let me do let me
run your merch let me take this burden
off your shoulders let me do your
distribution let me do your designs let
me let me do your mock-ups let me do
everything for you and
since you you know i know what they like
you can tell i know what they like it's
enough for this [ __ ] to go around so go
from doing a collab with somebody to
taking over their merch to where it gets
to the point where i'm doing i'm making
money in the background as i said once
you build that agency up to be really
like
consistent and you have that i mean with
all the relationships you have there's
no reason why yo thug let me handle your
merch
yo pump
let me do the merch yeah you know what
i'm saying i i just know you know they
like what you see you've seen me go from
zero to hero yeah so you know i know the
placements you know i know i know what
they like so i'm just using that to my
advantage right now
that's big man that's i mean [ __ ] dude i
just think like your story's so
inspiring so i think like for anybody
who's
you know like we talked about you down
and out or you just don't know like you
know at the end of the day man
not everything and and luckily for you
like what you're doing is is is is cool
is hip it's in but like
just the idea of building a business
doesn't always have to be glamorous it's
not easy
but if you put a thousand percent into
anything
like
your chances are that it's going to work
out it's a big it's a bigger chance of
it working out and you would make it
with some type of money then then a lot
of these other things if you're one put
in one foot out like it's like it's not
gonna work you gotta be ten toes down
just think how hard is it to pay six
dollars for a shirt
and sell it for even thirty dollars it's
not that hard
now you do that twenty times you do that
a hundred times do that 150 times
that's all residual income bro i'm not
saying you could still do whatever you
want to do
but you're going to see that putting
more time and effort into this i suggest
everybody to have some type of merch
office i suggest everybody any person
that has any type of platform i suggest
that they have a any type of merch
whether it's a t-shirt whether it's a
beanie whether it's a hoodie that you
drop um every other month every six
months is free money people i feel like
you should do a uh of a collab with the
full send guys on youtube
yeah
that's an awful lot of full sin would be
crazy that's fine i just i just ran
across them guys too him just got bro
they do
millions after this year though like i'm
telling like after this i'm probably
done with like doing collabs with
rappers
yeah yeah cause you i mean you've done
the big ones yeah it's like i'm like
like i might move on to pop i'm you know
i'm looking at licenses and [ __ ] like i
want to do an awful lot of spinach i
want to do some [ __ ] with popeye you
know what i mean like it's bigger things
out there than the rappers you know what
i mean
like i just tested the waters working
with like
food companies and i mean [ __ ] the west
coast customs thing was kind of you know
that's the company you know what i mean
that's that's a car shop you know what i
mean it's all like i'm just trying
different things you know but still
keeping it going you know it ain't gotta
all just be wrapped around rap you know
what i mean
i wanna do some [ __ ] about video games
that's an awful lot of madden you know
what i mean yeah stuff like that we just
used some of the like everywhere doing
some stuff with my boy cool car he got a
he got a shoe company you know what i
mean a collab with a shoe company
um
talk real quick plug the album with hip
boy oh awful lot of hits me and hit boy
um this album we made about a year ago
every beat is slamming all of this [ __ ]
is going crazy we just dropped the first
single awful lot of hits we're about to
drop another one intense and it's really
just songs just about my life and like
me going from like being like a hustler
to like being like a businessman you
know me in these la streets
hey man congrats bro
you're you're killing it bro
the clothes are fire
you got the so i mean look man tap in i
love the fact you got the van uh show
everyone the chain man
okay never forget where you came from
and you still got the van oh wait they
they tricked the van out of what's going
on oh the van is on 20 folds the van is
painted the van is wrapped the van is on
air bags the [ __ ] will sit down
to the ground like a little kid throwing
a temper tantrum you're never going to
get rid of that never that van to me is
like the statue of liberty in new york
like it's a la staple i didn't have that
van in every i didn't have that van
during the pandemic i didn't have that
van in the riots i didn't have that van
in the protest i didn't have that van
when did you pull up to the protests and
with gear ready to go yeah i'm putting
out with gear i just pulled up to the
protest with the van and i'm like
letting protesters sit on top of my bed
while i'm driving and we're honking you
know for freedom for for equality for
all that you know what i mean that van
is like an avid part of the community
you know i mean just all of the people
that would come down when i was in that
parking lot and take pictures to it i'll
never get rid of it did you document a
lot of this stuff everything is
documented so like in the parking lot
trapping you got bro i can go through my
archives right now you can i can go for
days and besides that i don't delete
posts yeah you gotta you gotta put a
little little docu-series out once you
know once it makes sense man yeah i'm
also i'm looking for you know i just got
to find the right person but my story i
just want to inspire people i just want
people to like like for a lot of times
because you think you either got to sell
dope
you know what i mean you got like these
are most people options as a kid because
i went through it first option is go to
college
that only works if you have some money
or you're super smart or you can sit
there because it's hard as [ __ ] to go to
college also go to college get a
four-year degree and end up a broke-ass
adult yeah you're gonna pay back college
loans and then working at some [ __ ]
job first one is college the second one
is trapping tried that got my ass booked
i spent three years in jail on christmas
i didn't see christmas for three years
trying to trap yeah you know what i mean
after trapping then in la you know
breaking in and stealing
pimping it's sports then it's rap you
don't have to do none of those bro start
a business grind put work into it you
know what i mean get a [ __ ] vending
machine dude anything bro like it's all
type of stuff besides those but that's
like those are the ones that everybody
glorifies my son's about to turn 16 and
all i'm getting him for i'm going to
spend like 500 on candy bars and chips
and [ __ ] for him to take to school and
sell that's where i started it's
literally
that's what he's getting for his
birthday that's where i started i used
to be the kid that they used to pick up
and they used to drop us off in front of
banks and in front of like different
stores with the box of candy and like
excuse me sir do you want to buy some
candy dollar candies we selling it for
like five yeah you know what i mean i
don't
know
you know in burbank they don't got like
a lot of like you know these healthy ass
[ __ ] that [ __ ] they took
that out to school a long time vending
machines are trash there you know so i'm
like bro i mean look i'm gonna give him
a little
hey look instead of me because he wanted
money and i was like why don't i just
give you
i'm gonna give you the option to turn
500 into a thousand
but you let's see what you're made of
you know what i'm saying let's see if
you like your pops i did that for my
brother this year like i buy him stuff
all type of stuff he loses jury he
wrecked cars so for this year i went and
bought him some merch boom
bought him some merch you sell this they
like myself so much you're my little
brother they're gonna think you're mine
yep i don't think this oh your brother
made this this is awful lot of coffee
sir yeah okay run it out of that yup yup
go hustle this [ __ ] listen man i
appreciate you coming through man that's
still dub my guy
awful lot of bootlegs stop playing with
us just go let's go let's go